his speech was closely watched by
friends and rivals looking for any
indication that Iran is willing to talk
to the US but President Hassan rouhani
made it clear he won't meet President
Donald Trump as long as the US continues
to impose sanctions mara demos are
Karimi hana they call us to negotiations
when they run away from treaties and
deals our response under sanctions is
negative
Iran's leader has called on regional
neighbors to join an alliance to secure
freedom of navigation in the Strait of
Hormuz where much of the world's oil
supply passes through well Hani excluded
the u.s. from taking part in what he
called the coalition of hope but the US
and Saudi Arabia have quickly dismissed
the proposal the European Union is keen
to cool the tension in the Gulf and
prevent further escalation it's top
diplomat federica mogherini says she
hopes the 2015 nuclear deal will
continue to be respected despite ongoing
differences we will continue to work
together with unity of purpose to try
and preserve it without ignoring the
challenges the Trump administration is
ramping up Russia on Iran US Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo sanctions and
isolation would continue until Iran's
nuclear ambitions are curved as long as
Iran's medicine behavior continues sank
continues sanctions will not be lifted
they will be tightened and the US and
Saudi Arabia continue to blame Iran for
the attacks on the world's largest oil
processing plant in the kingdom eleven
days ago Saudi diplomats have stepped up
their pressure saying all options
against Iran are all the tables Iran's
behavior cannot continue like this Iran
must abide by international law Iran
must comply with a rule-based
international order and the Iran's
aggressive behavior must be checked
the attacks took out nearly half of
Saudi oil production which the state oil
company our uncle is rushing to restore
as the US continues to build the case
against Iran rouhani warned against any
attack saying retaliation will quickly
follow the attacks on Saudi oil
installations threatened to be a
game-changer and could lead to a
military confrontation but the EU Russia
China and some countries in the Middle
East say the crisis should be solved
through dialogue and that escalation
would only further destabilize the
region [ __ ] Baba al Jazeera New York